Let's go next to a, I've got someone from
the two Oh two area code.
We didn't get your name last time you called,
but I have you as funny anti Biden guide.
Does that ring a bell?
Do you know who, who this is?
Yeah, I guess he talking about me.
That's you.
What was your name?
Uh, yeah.
Funny story.
Well, uh, and then so, okay.
About a while ago.
I mean, I think the first time I called was
about like, uh, uh, the, uh, the debate that
cow had was like do Rachel Justice and I was
the dude who said that.
That was like a political awakening for me.
Okay.
And what was your name?
Yeah, my name is Tommy.
You said, no, Mark me down a good color, but
then when next time I call you like, Oh, this
color, but I'd guess I don't know what his
name is.
I was like, wait, do you not remember me?
Wow.
Well listen, we got a lot of calls, but now
I'm going to make absolutely sure that we
have you labeled in full, fully, accurately.
It's fine.
Um, yeah.
So, uh, there was several things that was
like running through my mind, uh, recently.
Cause it's like sometimes I just like come
up with some stuff.
It's like, Oh, I can talk to somebody about
this political thing.
Uh, not to make people run on me I think are
that type of informed just to say that.
Mmm.
One thing that was kind of going through my
mind and I left, this is partly me not doing
as much research as I would like to do.
Uh, it was like, uh, the idea of Obama is
okay.
I remember, I recall reading something or
hearing something forth that said that he
had like a 90%, like a civilian casualty rate
was some as high as that when it came to like
him escalating with drone strikes or like
overseas war.
And I was like, you know, a lot of these savy
Creighton's will say that we need to like
basically indict lockup.
I know it was never going to happen, but with
me entitle lock up George Bush because of
his war crimes.
Right.
And I'm like, okay, it was being hypocrites,
but not saying the same thing about Obama.
Hmm.
Listen, I mean every president kills people
through foreign policy.
That's a reality.
And um, I mean, you know, we, we can take
one view, which is, uh, they should all be
locked up as war criminals.
We could take the view that that doesn't really
make sense because then, you know, there are
many, many, many presidents and prime ministers
who by that standard are war criminals and
it, and we sort of have to operate, uh, I
mean it's, it's, it's disappointing, but we
have to operate with a different barometer.
I guess I would say, which sounds absolutely
insane to say, but this is sort of the state
of, of the world affairs in 2019.
Um, but I completely understand what you're
saying.
Every president, you know, this idea of Hillary
was going to be killery and he'll kill all
these people.
Every president through foreign policy makes
decisions that lead to deaths that would otherwise
not happen.
Now, maybe other people would die if they
didn't make those decisions.
But this is a real complex issue.
Right.
Um, Oh no, I, I just bought a little thing
is like, the only thing that I would say is
that a gives me a dollar.
I got the little call.
Um, the other thing I would say is probably
like, Oh, uh, uh, should I just lost my train
of thought.
Yeah.
I apologize.
Hello, Tommy.
Oh, it seems like Tommy bailed when he lost
the sprint.
I thought that's weird.
Okay.
All right.
Well, Tommy, thank you for the call and we
hope to hear from you again.
Let's take a quick break.
Don't hang up if you're holding, because we
will go immediately back to the phones.
Right after this short break,